well a bipartisan group of lawmakers are
now looking to get the border surge
under control with a new immigration
bill
ernesto says border security is
paramount but he says it needs to be
done with immigration reform that does
not include citizenship
but does provide for legal status he is
congressman
carlos jimenez he's a republican from
florida who serves on the house homeland
security committee
and congressman you represent the bottom
part of florida uh you were born in cuba
welcome thank you for being here
first the border right now you visited
twice you're going to go back soon
to you what is the situation like and
what should be done
it's chaotic and there are a lot of
things that uh that bother me about
what's going on the the
the biden harris policies are
actually separating families uh at the
border because
uh young young kids under under uh 18
years old are allowed to stay on this
side and so what happens is
you know that's why we're seeing so many
unaccompanied minors crossing the border
thousands and thousands of them putting
them at at risk and danger
the policies are also enriching the
multinational cartels to the tunes of
hundreds of millions of dollars a month
we have policies now that we're actually
paying our contractors
on our side to not construct the wall
hundreds of millions of dollars
not to construct the wall part of that
wall is also a levee system
that is supposed to protect our
residents and our citizens from flooding
so that's not being done so there's a
whole myriad of stuff that's happening
at the
at the border that concerns me and uh
and the policies of the
this administration are to blame for
this surge that we're seeing
at the border yeah that's unbelievable
that they're being paid i guess they
must have the contracts you know you're
contracted to build the wall and if you
stop it you still got to pay the money
that's unbelievable
how do we fix this well i think that you
know we need to revert to some of the
policies that we had in the in the past
i mean uh
uh holding you know asylum seekers on
the mexican side of the border
will disincentivize people from coming
look if you know that you can get
uh to the other side to our side of the
rio grande
and and basically be processed and then
released into the country
you know you have a really good shot at
just staying here in the united states
which is your end game and so
uh the the old policy of processing them
at the other side of the border really
reduce the likelihood that you were ever
ever going to make it over successfully
uh by 90 percent and so you know people
understand the odds that's why you have
this huge surge and so
you know restoring those policies with
mexico restoring the policies
um and agreements that we had with
guatemala and
el salvador and honduras that needs to
be restored and then the rule of law we
need to add
additional additional judges at the
border so we can process these asylum
cases you know much quicker so there's a
whole myriad of stuff that we need to do
and it's really common sense we need to
follow what the customs and border
protection agents have said they need
more people they need
technology and they need infrastructure
and that infrastructure is actually
completing that wall
and so we've already going to spend the
money why don't you let the contractors
go ahead and finish
what they started so that we don't waste
tens if not hundreds of millions of
dollars and paying people not to do
anything
finally on that point i mean are you
surprised that most people don't know
that that they
just think you know they stop the wall
and we're paying for the wall not to be
built
yeah i think most people you know i
didn't know it until i got there and
then
our customs and border protection people
said oh by the way see all that all that
equipment
all that material etc we're paying those
contractors
not to build the wall to me that's
insanity
i mean you're paying not to build the
wall and the customs and border
protection people are saying
agents are saying we need that wall
those portions of the wall to be
completed
because that's a force multiplier it
actually at the end will save us money
we won't need as many
customs and border protection agents to
guard
the the border if we have the wall
if we have technology um you know and
and
restoration of some of these policies
and so uh you know to me it's it's
it's insanity and it's all ideological
uh it's got nothing to do with common
sense or what's really happening at the
border
well we're paying not to build the wall
says congressman carlos jimenez
from florida congressman thank you for
that surprising insight
and uh we want you back after you have
your next visit uh very shortly to the
border absolutely
thank you of course